Donkey Kong predates everybody and you
mentioned before that Mario was called
Jumpman and Donkey Kong fair enough now
what else was called Jumpman Michael
Jordan Mario isn't [__]
everybody
Sonic would Blaze ass on Mario I know
Sonic will be the underdog in this but
Sonic deserves leagues of respect Sonic
is the only when I forget the name of
the guy that took over Sega America but
everyone forgot his name well nobody you
couldn't his grave is unmarked
it says his personality is inspired by
Bill Clinton I don't quite get that but
Sonic everyone Sonic use that cigar on
Tails yeah yeah but Sonic
you know all those things that he loses
when you hit him the [__] rings actually
[Laughter]